en décembre dernier la ville de paris a
décidé de ne pas renouveler la
convention d'occupation domi domaniale
donc pour le marché de noël place et
tous les ans sur les champs elysées ce
marché noël attire environ 13 millions
de visiteurs en 2016 la mairie de
corbeil essonnes avait supprimé sa foi
et fête foraine annuel pour ne pas
augmenter ses impôts il ya eu la loi
sapin de également en plus de pays à
droite classe cette nouvelle loi permet
aux communes de choisir leur attraction
à leur corps vente avant certains
forains avaient un droit d'ancienneté
maintenant et doivent laisser des appels
d'offres à chaque ville des opérations
est escargot ont été organisées si cette
suite à cette annonce me marquent donc
et beaucoup de choses qui sont accumulés
pour les forains vous vous dites que ça
a été trop loin
karim zéribi je condamne la double
violence que je vois dans ce débat et le
double violence il ya d'abord une
violence d'état qui donne le sentiment
de vouloir faire disparaître une
profession qui serait fort et parce que
toutes les mesures que tu viens
d'évoquer sont des mesures effectivement
je dirais équipe qui pèsent sur des gens
qui viennent c'est 150 euros par mois
quand une fête foraine est un choeur de
centre ville y gagne ce que tu dis quand
elle est à 10 km y perdre 20 à 30% de
leur chiffre d'affaires
fête 20 30 % de moins que de 750 euros
c'est pas une violence ça quand on a une
famille quand c'est son boulot quand on
se lève le matin pour ça donc l'arrêt
une violence et de l'autre côté je peux
pas être d'accord avec les amis forains
sur la réaction qui est la violence je
peux pas être d'accord nous moi je suis
dans une posture où je condamne la
double violence parce que je pense
qu'une alternative c'est de belote
nawang le gouvernement peut les mettre
autour de la table mais franchement
allait les mettre à 10 km du centre
vivre c'est pourquoi
un communiqué commun cette fois c'était
c'était le moment de l'attractivité des
divertissements pour des familles et
c'est ça qui n'auraient pas la voiture
est qu'ils pouvaient venir oui mais à
dix kilomètres soit posée justement à
pascal fons personne qui est député donc
la république en marge de la fsa moi je
vous dis la vérité j'ai la même analyse
un peu que karim zéribi moi franchement
les fêtes foraines moi c'était une autre
qui fâche les bretons allaient d'où
venaient dans les fêtes foraines poumons
qui fait on était content là j'ai
l'impression qu'on est dans une société
où tout devient un problème il n'y avait
pas de problème avec l'effet de serre
est loin on est en train d'en créer un
tout et là je comprend pas comment on a
tous envie nous on est où on est et on
voit là les îles et à des jeunes qui ont
envie d'aller des familles ils ont
utilisé leur accueil doivent se taper 10
km pour aller à la fête foraine c'est à
dire tout est venue compliquer expliquez
moi pourquoi pascal fontenelle alors moi
déjà je voulais vous dire que j'ai
accepté de venir à cette émission
lorsque j'ai reçu les à l'assemblée
nationale hier les forains d'accord des
forains qui ont voulu mme pagé pas de
mandat local donc je ne peux pas
intervenir sur ce qui se passe sur la
ville du mans directement au niveau du
nom dialogue avec le maire par contre je
voudrais pas que cette fête populaire
que je connais depuis que je suis tout
petit et que je connais toujours pas ce
que j'emmène mes petits enfants
régulièrement à la fête foraine
je voudrais pas que cette fête foraine
qui sont une fête populaire devienne
impopulaire
je voudrais pas qu'on ait peur des gens
qui vendent la barbe à papa que mes
petits enfants dit il ému il est méchant
le monsieur qui me vend la barbe à papa
j'ai pas envie de ça apaisé ça doit
faire rêver
oui mais pour diriger neige il ya une
génèse au niveau de l'environnement eau
ni je vais prendre je vais vous prendre
l'exemple de la ville du mans il ya eu
des travaux vous le savez sur le
centre-ville au tram a été construit et
vous avez négocié très longtemps avec le
maire jean claude boulard qui est décédé
pour pouvoir justement vous exportez
quelques temps et revenir au centre
ville mais la configuration la
physionomie elle-même de la ville ne
supporte plus finalement la physionomie
de cette même fête foraine donc
aujourd'hui sarah génère un gros
problème économique pour vous et moi je
suis là aussi parce que je me suis pas
fait élire et ni engagé il ya 18 mois
pour que j'ai pour générer des problèmes
économiques mais en même temps
chez sea shipping le bloc junin-6 crimes
extrêmes ainsi si je puis m'exprimer
ainsi
en même temps je ne vois pas comment on
va s'en sortir sans dialogue
la violence n'est pas un dialogue dont
on tourne à la guerre et qu'on veut si
on se met à la blague réputé est ce que
vous comprenez qu'il ya urgence pour
certaines personnes
soprano ouvertes des millions d'euros il
est urgent vierge en but et nos gènes si
vous voulez actuellement avec cette
ordonnance qui est vraiment mortifère
pour la professionnelle fait 20 mois
correct là ça fait vingt mois d'affilée
même chose moi je fais partie de la
commission
je suis comme heather au visage mais si
on permettait alors regarder si vous
avez accès à des crédits vous avez accès
à des banques
tout cela il travaille ok ben maintenant
le monde forain n'aura plus accès aux
bons angles ex pourquoi et parce qu'ils
avaient un fonds de commerce avec les
emplacements qu'ils avaient à fond de
commerce avec les fêtes foraines et
maintenant son commerce ils auront pu
boxer qui vont aller prendre des crédits
madame mes moyens voilà alors choisir
les angles et renouveler les manèges
tourner notre tournée c'est notre fonds
de commerce et moi aussi mais on peut
pas porter alors au niveau de la ville
dimanche vers eux
recentré un peu le débat sur la vie il
avait promis la dpj
stéphane le foll qui est nouveau heures
du mans a fait des promesses électorales
il va devoir attendre le tgv soit 58
minutes de paris c'est une population
parisienne et à lyon centre ville et ne
nous aurait fait plus de cent d'oubli
ski alors attendez n'oubliera bailleul
qui me gêne un peu c'est qu'on oublie ce
qui s'est passé l'année dernière au mans
exactement
à la fête foraine au mois de mars 2010
m'appeler nous ce qui s'est passé il ya
eu des incidents répétés pendant la
première semaine du mois de mars pendant
la fête foraine où il ya eu des
incidents entre des jeunes et des
forains il faudra qu'ils voulaient
refaire leurs polices eux-mêmes on a été
obligés de mouvements du jeu on a été
obligé de mobilisé 650 policiers les 46
150 policiers sur quinze jours jour et
nuit pour faire en sorte qu' on puisse
venir à la fête foraine et que ça se
passe dans les meilleures positions
possibles donc il ya déjà une question
de sécurité publique et de moyens
engagés
est ce que c'est normal qu'on soit
obligé de mettre autant de moyens et
leur exemple
apic du mans et les révélations question
monsieur est que lorsque la ville du
mans et monsieur vouloir à l'époque
avait mis à disposition passée d'un
terrain de 7000 m² dans le centre du
mans on vous a donné trois hectares à 6
km2 du mans à un quart d'heure en
tramway c'est important de le préciser
quand même c'est pas non plus et à côté
du sien vous laissez moi vous dire
qu'ils les 24 heures du mans quelque
chose de cuivre à mon bien
si l'année dernière si c'est quand la
fête au panorama s'est passé à l'automne
là bas il n'y a pas eu un incident fini
tu finis par la question je finis
monsieur complément un argument sur les
clients sur les 7000 m² il y avait 60 de
forains installés raid installés dans le
centre-ville du mans appartement moment
où vous amis au panorama vous êtes
retrouvés à trensacq moi je suis pas
super bon en économie mais je sais que
diviser la part du gâteau à 105
ça fait moi parfois sans ben c'est pour
ça qu'il faut comprendre le centre-ville
et ben non alors on ira sans mère
voulait d'ailleurs
ces deux fonctions il ya un choix n'est
qu'un problème entre eux il ya un
problème entre vous est ce que vous
voulez pas laisser travailler à temps
des relations avec leurs lots alors si
en plus maintenant que votre à celle de
votre argument ça veut dire que quand il
ya un problème de sécurité on supprime
l'événement pourquoi vous supprimez
trophy qui vont se battre dans le métro
vous mettez de la police fait vous
supprimez pas le métro vous ne la voyez
pas ça kilomètres de la ville le métro
je suis content je pense que c'est un
dialogue qui devrait être serein autour
d'une table et personne n'arrive à le
faire ce qui lui plaît
les nationales bernal à paris le mans
series kg bien c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai qu'il est intolérable et la
violence sont peu partout les règles
c'est sympa de violence et un blessé
grave
d'accord avec vous mais c'est la merde
comme vous dites il ya eu des chiffres
de l'an dernier si moi je suis le maire
du mans je vais voir ces forêts et je
leur ai écouté je vais tout faire pour
que vous restiez là mais par contre je
vous garantie d'une chose je ne veux pas
décider
je veux que tout se passe bien cette
fois ce sera terminé ça c'est du
dialogue je suis je suis chaufferie que
ses fans de folie
oui mais il y aura plus de dialogue mais
il faut du dialogue